tenemos aquí tres ecuaciones y cuatro
incógnitas o sea cuatro variables
desconocidas y en esos casos siempre que
tenemos menos ecuaciones que incógnitas
seguramente ya lo sabes o te lo puedes
imaginar nuestro sistema de ecuaciones
no tiene una solución única no estamos
restringiendo a nuestras variables
desconocidas lo suficiente como para que
un solo punto sea la solución aquí lo
que tenemos son 1234 variables por lo
tanto las soluciones van a estar entre 4
y pues como tenemos menos ecuaciones que
variables desconocidas entonces nuestra
solución va a ser digamos no sé un plano
que no abarca en su totalidad ar4 pero
tampoco es un punto y por ejemplo si
tuviéramos tres variables desconocidas
el número de cuatro y tuviéramos nada
más dos ecuaciones en lugar de tres la
solución sería una línea recta
que si es más restringido que un plano
pero de todas formas tiene una infinidad
de puntos en ella entonces hay una
infinidad de soluciones y bueno hemos
resuelto ya varias veces estos sistemas
de ecuaciones utilizando un método de
eliminación pero lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es utilizar matrices las
matrices lo que son realmente es nada
más un arreglo de números y pues son
mucho más sencillas son más fáciles de
escribir escribe uno menos cosas y todo
sale mucho más rápido con ellas lo que
vamos a hacer es tomar los coeficientes
de las variables
entonces vamos a crear la matriz de
coeficientes de estas ecuaciones bueno
del lado izquierdo del igual de estas
ecuaciones y entonces en la primera
columna lo que vamos a hacer es escribir
los coeficientes de la variable x 1 y en
la primera fila lo que vamos a hacer es
escribir los coeficientes de la primera
ecuación entonces aquí en este lugar va
este coeficiente que es un 1
aquí va uno
y aquí va a 12 ahora aquí va a 12
y después un 4 y por acá va un 1
que es el coeficiente de la variable x 3
en la primera ecuación después va a 12
que es este coeficiente pero a ahora el
coeficiente de la variable x 3 en la
tercera ecuación es cero porque aquí no
aparece en ningún lado de la ecuación x
3 o sea que el coeficiente de x3 es cero
y aquí va a un 1
aquí va un -1 porque la variable x4 se
está restando menos 1 y por acá va un 6
entonces esta es la matriz de
coeficientes de este sistema de
ecuaciones pero además quiero hacer una
matriz aumentada o sea que aquí lo vamos
a poner en lugar de cerrar el paréntesis
de la matriz vamos a poner una línea y
de hecho vamos a usar otro color y de
este lado lo que vamos a poner es lo que
hay del lado derecho del igual de las
ecuaciones o sea aquí en la primera
ecuación tenemos un 7 y después tenemos
un 12 y un 4
y la parte padre de usar estas matrices
en lugar de los sistemas de ecuaciones
tal cual es que aquí ya no tenemos que
escribir un millón de veces para en este
caso son tres veces x 1 x 1 x1 y x2 y x
4 y todo eso pero pues esta es una
representación de estas ecuaciones
entonces lo que podemos hacer es por
ejemplo a esta fila la podemos
multiplicar por un escalar al igual que
podíamos multiplicar esta ecuación por
un escalar y también podemos agarrar una
fila y restar sela a la de arriba y
tomar una fila y reemplazarla por esa
fila por una constante más cualquier
otra de las filas entonces pues vamos a
usar esta representación de las
ecuaciones para resolverlo y encontrar
la solución y bueno lo que hacíamos
principalmente cuando estábamos con
estas ecuaciones es tratar de dejar una
variable solita es tratar de dejar un 1
aquí y que en el resto de la columna hay
apuro ceros o sea tratar de dejar que la
primera entrada de la ecuación
en lugar de un 2 y hacer que en el resto
de la columna haya puro ceros y bueno a
esa forma de la matriz le llamamos
convencionalmente forma escalonada
reducida por filas forma escalonada
reducida por filas y si por ejemplo esta
matriz es la matriz a lo que queremos
hacer es transformar esta matriz a su
forma escalonada reducida por filas
porque así es mucho más fácil encontrar
las soluciones a este sistema y bueno la
convención general es que las matrices
las denotamos por letras mayúsculas la
diferencia de los vectores que los
denotamos por letras minúsculas
más adelante en algunos otros vídeos
vamos a ver cuál es la relación entre
las matrices y los vectores pero por el
momento vamos a ver cómo se transforman
estas matrices a su forma escalonada
reducida por filas
entonces ya que tenemos un uno aquí
vamos a empezar por hacer que el resto
de las entradas de esta columna de esta
cosa sean cero
así es que esta fila esta cosa la vamos
a dejar exactamente igual entonces aquí
tenemos un 1 2 1
después tenemos
7 y para hacer que esta cosa sea un 0
vamos a reemplazar esta fila esta cosa
por la primera fila menos esta fila ok
entonces tenemos 1 - 1 0
2 - 2
0 1 2 - 1 - 11 - menos 1 eso es uno más
uno o sea 2
7 - 12 eso es menos 5 y ya conseguimos
que en este lugar haya un 0 y usamos
puras operaciones que pudimos haber
hecho con este sistema de ecuaciones o
sea lo que hicimos fue reemplazar esta
ecuación por la ecuación que resulta de
a esta ecuación restarle esta ecuación y
eso siempre lo pudimos hacer para
resolver este sistema de ecuaciones
entonces bueno vamos ahora a hacer que
esta entrada se vuelva a cero y para
hacer eso lo que vamos a hacer es a esta
ecuación restarle dos veces esta
ecuación aunque entonces dos menos dos
por uno
eso es cero
que es justo lo que queremos hacer
después cuatro menos dos por dos o sea
cuatro menos cuatro eso también es cero
y 0 - 2 x 1 esto es 0 - 2 o sea menos 2
menos 2 por 1 6 menos 2
eso es 4 y ahora 4 menos 2 por 7 2 por 7
son 14 4 - 14 eso es menos 10 y aquí nos
quedaron muchos ceros más adelante vamos
a ver qué significa eso de que aquí en
toda esta columna nos hayan quedado
puros ceros pero si aquí nos hubiera
quedado cualquier otro número cualquier
otro real lo que habríamos hecho sería
multiplicar esta ecuación por 1 entre
este número para que nos quedara un 1
por acá y después haríamos que esta
entrada se volviera a 0 cosa que pues
realmente no tendríamos que hacer nada
porque está allá de cero ahora ya que no
tenemos ninguna entrada en esta columna
que sea distinta de cero pues nos
tenemos que mover a la siguiente columna
y aquí ya tenemos algo distinto de cero
que queremos convertir en un 1 entonces
para que esto se vuelva un 1 nada más
tenemos que multiplicar todas
y la por un -1 y para hacerlo pues no
tenemos que volver a escribir toda la
matriz ósea podemos simplemente aquí
ponerle esto para que sea menos por
menos da más aquí ya tenemos el 1 que
estábamos buscando aquí el 2 lo
multiplicamos por menos uno y nos queda
menos dos y aquí el menos cinco lo
más cinco y ahora si queremos hacer que
todas las entradas de esta columna sean
cero y para eso sí tenemos que volver a
escribir la matriz entonces vamos a
volver a escribir nuestra matriz
aumentada pero ahora haciendo que esta
entrada se vuelva cero y ésta también
así es que esta matriz es igual
vamos a dejar esta fila tal cual como
está entonces tenemos aquí un cero otro
cero luego un 1 luego un -2 y la matriz
está aumentada y aquí tenemos del otro
lado del igual un 5
ahora como aquí tenemos un -2 y aquí
tenemos un 1 lo que podemos hacer para
que esto se vuelva 0 es a esta ecuación
sumarle dos veces esta ecuación
y eso es lo que vamos a hacer así es que
tenemos cero más dos veces cero
igual aquí
y menos dos más dos por uno eso es menos
dos más dos o sea 0 que es justo lo que
estábamos buscando y ahora cuatro más
dos por menos dos o sea cuatro menos
cuatro eso nos da cero y finalmente
menos diez más dos por cinco o sea diez
menos diez más 10 cero mira nada más
toda la ecuación se volvieron ceros
bueno cuando estábamos resolviendo estos
sistemas de ecuaciones por el método de
eliminación no nos preocupábamos si por
ejemplo esta entrada que está arriba de
la primera entrada distinta de cero de
esta fila de esta ecuación era 0 o 1 o
sea la dejábamos tal cual como estaba y
nada más nos preocupábamos por hacer que
todas las de abajo se volvieran 0 pero
para hacer la forma escalonada reducida
por filas si vamos a hacer que las
entradas de arriba también se vuelvan 0
y entonces para hacer que ésta se vuelva
0 lo que vamos a hacer es a esta fila a
esta ecuación restarle una sola vez esta
fila aunque y entonces uno menos cero
eso sigue siendo un 1 menos mal porque
queremos siempre tener unos como el
primer valor distinto de cero de las
filas
entonces 20 sigue siendo 2
1 - 1 ahora si ya tenemos el 0 que
estábamos buscando y 1 menos -2 eso es 1
2 que es 3 y 7 menos 5 2 y entonces ya
tenemos esta matriz en su forma
escalonada reducida por filas
la matriz ah ok por qué pues porque
estas entradas que son las primeras
entradas distintas de 0 de izquierda a
derecha que además le llama entradas
pivote entrada pivote que hay entrada
pivote son todas un 1 ok si aquí
tuviéramos un 5 lo que tendríamos que
hacer es dividir toda la ecuación entre
5 para que aquí nos quedara un 1 todas
las entradas pivote tienen que ser 1 y
además tenemos que todas las filas que
se convirtieron en ceros estas filas de
ceros que en este caso sólo hay una que
es esta fila de ceros tiene que estar
hasta abajo y lo último que nos falta
para que esté en su forma escalonada
reducida por filas bueno nos falta decir
dos cosas pero una de ellas es que cada
entrada pivote tiene que estar a la
derecha de todas las entradas pivote de
arriba
ok esta entrada pivote está a la derecha
de esta entrada pivote y la otra cosa
que ya hemos dicho es que en la columna
en la que se encuentra una entrada
pivote tiene que haber puros ceros en
las otras ecuaciones en las otras filas
entonces en la columna de esta entrada
pivote hay puros ceros si
definitivamente sí y en la columna de
esta otra entrada pivote hay puros ceros
entonces esta matriz definitivamente si
está en su forma escalonada reducida por
filas enumerando lo otra vez las
entradas pivote tienen que ser 1 las
filas que son 0 tienen que estar hasta
abajo de la matriz en cada columna en la
que haya una entrada pivote la única
entrada distinta de 0 es justo la
entrada pivote y todas las entradas
pivote están a la derecha de las
entradas pivote de las ecuaciones que
estén arriba de esa ecuación
y listo
ahora como dijimos al principio cada uno
de estos números es el coeficiente de
alguna de estas variables en una de
estas ecuaciones por ejemplo este es el
coeficiente de x 1 en esta ecuación
entonces podemos regresar a las
ecuaciones y vamos a reconstruir a
partir de estos coeficientes el sistema
de ecuaciones aquí tenemos uno de x 1 en
la primera ecuación + 2 2 x 2 más y
tenemos cero como coeficiente de la
variable x 3 en la primera ecuación o
sea que aquí tenemos que dejar un
espacio del x 3 y aquí nos queda más 3
veces x 4 3 x x 4
y este es el número que queda del lado
derecho del igual o sea que aquí tenemos
que la primera ecuación es esto igual a
2 y ahora vamos con la segunda ecuación
tenemos cero como coeficiente de la
primera variable aleatoria cero como
coeficiente de x2 y ahora sí una vez x 3
más menos 2 veces x 4 menos dos por x 4
y eso es igual a 5
y bueno en nuestra tercera ecuación
tenemos puros ceros o sea aquí podríamos
escribir cero igual a cero pero para qué
hacernos pato mejor no andamos jugando
esta ecuación no nos aporta nada de
información así es que hemos logrado
reducir este sistema de ecuaciones a
este sistema de ecuaciones de dos
ecuaciones y a las variables cuyo
coeficiente es la entrada pivote de la
matriz en su forma escalonada reducida
por filas les llamamos variables pivote
aunque hay entonces ésta es una variable
pivote y ésta también es una variable
pivote que variable pivote y a las
variables que quedan las que no están
asociadas con ninguna entrada pivote o
sea que no son variables pivote les
llamamos variables libres ok entonces x
2 y x 4 las dos son variables libres
variables libre
aunque hay entonces resolvamos el
sistema bueno de hecho como mencionamos
al principio no vamos a poder resolver
tal cual el sistema no vamos a encontrar
una solución única un punto único que
resuelva el sistema este tampoco porque
aquí nada más tenemos dos ecuaciones y
cuatro variables entonces de hecho vamos
a tener una infinidad de soluciones lo
único que sí vamos a poder resolver son
qué valor tienen que tomar las variables
pivote ok qué valor tiene que tomar x 1
y x 3 bueno de hecho no todos los puntos
van a tener el mismo valor en x 1 y en x
3 pero hay algo muy parecido
entonces lo que estas ecuaciones nos
dicen es que x 3 es igual a 5 + x 4 5 y
pasamos a este menos x 4 del otro lado y
nos queda más 2 x 4 y de esta ecuación
lo que obtenemos despejando x 1 dejando
a x 1 solita es x 1 es igual a 2
2 - 2 x 2 menos 2 x 2 menos 3 x 4 menos
3 x 4 y esto es lo más cercano que
podemos llegar a obtener a una solución
del sistema de ecuaciones ok y estos
valores
x 4 y x2 que son las variables libres
los podemos asignar cualquier valor que
se nos ocurra y dados esos valores pues
ya tenemos exactamente cuáles son x 3 y
x1 ok es por estos x 4 y x 2 que le
podemos asignar el valor que se nos
ocurra que tenemos una infinidad de
soluciones y no nada más una pero bueno
voy a escribir este par de soluciones de
otra forma que nos va a ayudar a
entender otras cosas
y otras cosas como cuál es el conjunto
de soluciones del sistema entonces vamos
a escribir esto como
un vector aquí va a ser x 1 x 2 x 3 y x
y este vector es igual
a ver a ver aquí tenemos que x 1 es
igual a 2 entonces vamos a poner un 2
por aquí y aquí tenemos menos 2 veces x
2 así es que pues déjame ponerlo como
más
x2 por una cosa por acá
que en la primera entrada como estamos
con x uno va a tener menos dos más y
ahora vamos a ponerle x cuatro por otra
cosa
ok esto esto es simplemente otra forma
de escribir estas ecuaciones que hay
aquí tenemos que en el x1 tiene menos 3
x 4 entonces aquí vale menos 3 entonces
tal cual tal cual lo que esto esto y
esto y esto y esto nos está diciendo
esta primera fila digamos es justo lo
mismo que nos está diciendo esta
ecuación aunque hay que x 1 es igual al
2 solito más x 2 x menos 2 aquí está tal
cual más x 4 x menos 3 bien entonces
vamos a ver qué es lo que nos dice esta
otra ecuación ok es lo que nos dice es
que x 3 o sea que nos vamos a ir al
nivel x 3 es igual a un 5 solito sin
variable aquí va un 5 más
x 2 x pues aquí no hay ningún x2
entonces aquí le tenemos que poner un
cero para que sea cero veces x2
+ 2 x x 4 así es que aquí va su 2 bueno
ya ahora tenemos que completar estos
vectores y para hacerlo aquí tenemos un
x2 que es exactamente igual a una vez x2
sin que le tengamos que sumar nada de x
4 y tampoco ningún escalar por acá y lo
mismo x 4 es igual a 1 por x 40 x x 2 +